what up guys welcome to the chest pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to like the
video on your way in and subscribe to
the channel a like is the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these streams also we're trying to hit 2
million subscribers before the end of
the year also guys make sure you get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
you know you could be the ultimate alpha
male women will come up to you left
right and Center just saying you are so
amazing and awesome get yourself a
t-shirt today okay so today's topics
guys okay so guys about five months ago
there was a woman that I kicked off of
the pregame and what I cannot stand is
when people come onto my show with a
preconceived notion about me and already
have an agenda they're trying to push so
this woman um I ended up kicking her off
the show let me let me show you guys the
because traditionally the woman has
being the one who stays at home
Cooks but why but why are we punishing
the men for doing what they're supposed
to do like you want you got wait wait
you want a guy that protects and
provides right that's what we
traditionally want but when a guy do
does it he loses his kids no one said
that's what we should you should punish
them cuz like men and women are
different men go and build houses women
look after their kids women build houses
men can look after kids there are stay
home dads who do exactly the same job as
women when the women are out there
earning the bread like that's a minority
of Rel
does happen you you need to accept that
that does happen we know like duh but
it's like we don't have to we just said
let's not acknowledge every exception we
know there's every there was are
exceptions and you the first thing you
say here's the exception we know we know
I think what the lady is simply doing is
trying to bring up the facts and I agree
that we should actually be holding men
and women equally accountable because we
should be saying there are men who
should take
responsibility let me finish let me
finish I was speaking
okay get out go go bye I told you no I
told you a millionth time I haven't done
anything wrong okay all right bye why
what why why why do you want me to I'm
asking you to go thank you you don't
like the fact that I'm challenging your
viewpoints no I don't really people
challenge my viewpoints all the time I
don't I don't like that you're being
rude I'm not being
rude
okay
nice to meet
you feminists P do you not like it when
people have opinions no she her asked
her to stop multiple times and she
didn't she there's a rule we were told
the rules before we came so yeah but she
did try and talk a few times and P
didn't let her talk she just told her
show all right all right because it's
not your show if you want to put on a
show and talk when you want to talk show
not that good I've never heard of it
it's only fans hand you don't know
live streams every Friday and Saturday
oh my God on
Sunday so this show was interesting and
I actually I got a bit of flak for this
because they were like why don't you
just let her talk and the problem you
get in is as a show host people go on
long tangents that go off topic and if
you don't get people to stick to the
point then you end up with an outof
control show and I'll even say as a HST
like this is probably the hardest thing
to balance is like controlling your
guests at this woman the whole show
she's accusing me of being a liar and
it's interesting because they don't go
on the show in good faith now what is
good faith it's assuming the best in
people and you get people that already
don't like you they already have an
agenda they're trying to go viral
they're really just coming on the show
to go viral and it's interesting because
I saw another video of this woman go
viral this week I got a lot of flak for
it they said Pearl just let your guests
do whatever you want and it was so funny
because the one
chick she was like she was like oh I put
on a show too I'm like [__] you're on
only
fans get out of here okay but anyways
let's let's pull up the next one um as
you guys if you guys remember last week
I had a discussion uh with our sister
what was your name sister zarena Matra
sister zarena Matra so we had a
discussion we started off with a green
which was about feminism and you know
all the stuff that they say so we was in
agreement with that we had a difference
of opinion certain matters and it was
look discussions happen discussions are
not where we speak to people that we
agree with I'll be honest I have a
podcast which is called uh bitter truth
and I invite people that I disagree with
so it's totally understandable that we
had some disagreements however you did
come back today and I think you wanted
to maybe please tell us I I mean I don't
I don't want to speak for you please
tell us what happened well you see in
the comments of the video a lot of
people said that I was trash and loose
and run through and you're absolutely
right I am run through and that is
exactly why I believe that Islam is the
solution because you see for horish
Western women like myself we certainly
need Islam to teach us a good
lesson okay okay sister what I will say
is this following I would say firstly
ignore the comments uh anybody that's
called you a whatever I don't want to
repeat after but it was thanks to you
you a thumbnail of me like that didn't
you Ally okay so all right so I think I
think okay so let's let's let's come to
Let's I unless people that didn't know
anything about me trash CH about me in
the [__] comments do you have
something think I that made me feel
listen to me I am not a piece of [__]
where the women are not trash okay there
is nothing wrong with the way I was
dressed you set me up I didn't know what
a [__] debate you be of [__] now
listen this is who I am this is who I am
you have 1 million subscribers Ali you
could have used it to help me you could
have used it to help somebody smaller
than you what a [__] a big con decorator
because okay are sure people much
smaller than them I am not trash I an
author and a musician and a YouTuber
okay
what no that was wrong that thumbnail
was wrong okay you don't treat people
like that you don't treat people like
that oh I was being sarcastic for God's
sake I want you I don't want you to look
at me for God's sake okay you tell your
audience that the IQ a [__] bubblebee
I'm sorry I said that I would rather
hang myself than become a muslim okay it
was rude I did not mean that but For
Heaven's Sake you did not need to set me
up like that I did not want to debate
you you should not have done that to me
that is not how we treat people are you
finish this though no I'm a person I did
not deserve that I to sit there my
brother had to see those comments you
know what your [__] followers said to
me that was rude
you said men use women for sex you use
the woman for likes on
YouTube 100,000 views I will get my
right arm to have 100,000 views on the
YouTube channel Al
want 100,000 views make a me like a
piece of [__] so you can have a good
laugh about it did you make a lot of
money out of that video did you have a
nice week eh I got 300 [__]
subscribers I thought we were going to
have an intelligent discussion about
feminism I thought we going to been a
very Gable discussion a Muslim and
Muslim talking about feminism but no you
made me look like a piece of [__] it was
horrible imagine if my dad saw that
there was nothing wrong with the way I
dressed Western women are not trash okay
just because you don't want to wear
buers and not make us trash for the I am
not a be of [__] he set me up you knew
exactly what you did you set me up
finish finish it was rude finish your
you not have done that to me you could
not have done that to me okay sister
finish your claim then I can talk just
tell me you're making
accusations I don't want to say anything
else to you you take this take thank you
thank you very much I don't know what
got do me okay so let's just yeah let's
just bring some
clarification what the what was the
thumbnail that said they have the
picture of the
thumbnail why she lost it I mean if
anything he's helping her dress more
modestly with the the thing okay so
there was a couple things that she said
that were interesting she said she would
cut her right arm off for 100,000 views
this is a woman that is going around
trying to go viral and then gets mad at
the consequences guys I have gone viral
for many things all right many things in
my career and I am well aware that
comments will be positive and comments
will be negative you cannot control the
comment section sometimes the comment
section loves me sometimes the comment
section hates me it's part of life and
being on the internet so she also said
she would rather hang
herself um I I I didn't write down the
full quote but it was something along
the lines of yeah it was I would rather
hang myself than read the Quran she she
puts out disrespect and then wonders why
people are disrespectful towards her and
women like this go around they go
through life they just live in la la
land and they have no idea how they come
off to other people
this girl had been read the rules so
many times on my show she knew what she
was signing up for we tell them look it
sometimes as a host we have to interrupt
to control the flow of the conversation
it's nothing against you we read them
these rules before the show and I know
that when I go on other shows it's just
part of being a show host but she comes
in she tries to insinuate I'm a liar and
then wonders why I'm not overly patient
with her she goes around being
completely disrespectful to people and
then
wonders why they do not give her the
benefit of the doubt and what I really
wanted to point out is what we can learn
from this
situation guys I think that half of
women have a mental disorder I think
half of women today really if you push
them even if it's completely reasonable
if you disagree with them in the
slightest many have this reaction we
have many women that are going around
literally with mental disorders this is
not normal this is not healthy and I
think partially the media plays into it
I think a lot of times it's off Family
Dynamics I don't really know um it's
funny because the thumbnail says why she
lost it I mean the question is did you
lose it or did you not lose it and just
based off of this picture she seems
pretty pretty upset and then instead of
taking accountability for her action she
goes around and blames everybody else
it's the YouTuber's problem and the
funny thing is the way his mics are set
up you literally have to hook up your
mic so you know exactly what you're
doing you know what you're signing up
for but women want to sign up for this
stuff and then play the victim later and
and the thing is women like this they
age quickly but if you don't want to age
quickly did you know that one of the
leading reasons that skin begins to Sag
and form wrinkles is not necessarily
because of old age but because our
bodies are missing out in essential
collagen you see we produce 10% less
collagen every decade once we hit 30 and
that's a major reason behind those pesty
wrinkles that's why myself along with
tens of thousands of people have turned
to this Cutting Edge new substance to
help reduce visible signs of aging it
uses the top five most researched types
of collagen which is essential for skin
Health to support skin elasticity and
skin hydration the best part is you get
53% off for the rest of the month until
they sell out whatever comes first get
yours now by going to health withth
pearl.com that's Health withth pearl.com
you will not regret it um okay guys so
sometimes I go on Tik Tok and Tik tok's
interesting I usually go on to catch up
on my True Crime I've been following the
Idaho murders case lately that's that's
a that's a good one but a lot of times
on K Tik Tock I just see these like
crazy conspiracy theories about me or
just all these people just you know I'm
not too popular on Tik Tok I guess but
there was a woman um that I guess
destroyed me I guess I have been
destroyed on Tik Tok and I'm very
excited to see it I guess she gave me
some Lo logic and facts and I'm super
excited to see it enlighten me feminist
know the people that believe in divorce
go be in long-term relationships leave
marriage for the people that actually
believe in For Better or For Worse for
richer or for poor in sickness and in
health till death do
do you know what drives me nuts about
this clip is that she's operating off a
premise that women are getting married
with the intention of getting divorced
but they're not making commitments with
the intention of breaking them they're
just making commitments to men who are
careful not to reveal themselves until
after the wedding is over and that
happens because of how seriously women
take their commitments they fight so
hard to keep their families together and
they've been conditioned to be the one
who feels fault if it fails and people
can end up taking advantage of that
women end up staying when they should
probably leave because they've been sold
the myth of the infamous rough patch and
they keep telling themselves it will get
better despite the fact that it keeps
getting worse they sacrifice themselves
for what they've been told is the good
of the family so these women end up
being abused because of how sacred they
hold their vows and yet you have the
audacity to act like they're just
walking away like it means nothing
they're not just walking away because
he's poor than the day they met in fact
she usually gets a second job if he
loses his and continues to cooked in her
nightly and that's also why she hasn't
had her nails done in 7 years if you
even bother to ask her marriage vows me
so much to so many people but you do not
stand on an altar and say For Better or
For Worse and to my own destruction
women stay for the love they have for
who that man used to be or because their
family threatens to disown them or
because a church told them that that's
their Duty or because they have a child
who looks up at them and ask them where
daddy is at bedtime this is not as easy
as you make it out to be and you need to
stop shaming people for living a life
you've never lived you don't get to
interpret someone's vows unless you've
walked in their shoes and lived with
their partner behind closed doors
because For Better or For Worse should
never mean staying in a situation that's
worse than you ever could have imagined
what
what well let me let me get this
straight For Better or For Worse should
not mean staying in a situation that is
worse than you imagine what well when
women imagine that marriage is going to
be this Disney fairy tale that's so
amazing and
awesome of course I expect them to stay
together even if it's worse than they
imagin so let's let's go through her
claims okay because I wrote some of
these down one women are not getting
abused left right and Center no no no no
no no that is not the case and I will
have to beat this out of you guys no
stop saying that women are the more
likely party to be abused most abusive
situations the parties are abusing each
other sorry guys but you attract what
you are if you are constantly attracting
abusive Partners it is possible that
maybe you are abusive as well when it
comes to one-sided abuse where one party
is hitting the other and they are not
reciprocating even with the Under
reporting that we know men under report
this stuff women are more likely to be
abusive than be abused women are just as
abusive if not more abusive than men um
the second thing that she points out I
want you to see how women view
commitment men care about actions your
intentions do not matter I don't care if
you took the vows and didn't intend to
get divorced if you still got divorced
because you saw some Tik toks sorry this
idea that women are leaving left and
right for good reasons it's just not
true most of the time when women leave
it's because they are not submissive
they were not raised to be a wife and
they do not take their vows seriously
they were sold a Disney Dream that their
husband should have everything and will
have no flaws and are in a gynocentric
social order that tells them they're
amazing special and awesome all the time
and never talk about what they do wrong
in a
relationship women overwhelmingly do not
fight for marriages men put up with fat
wives they put up with wives that do not
sleep with them and they put up with
controlling wives all because they care
about the children but women will
divorce men because the man says please
don't go to the club sweetheart or maybe
you don't get your nails done for S
years notice how in her language she
talks about how getting your nails done
is something you're entitled to even
though she hasn't had her nails done in
seven years ladies why is this stuff so
important why do you feel titled to
makeup Botox and getting your nails done
once you have a child it's not about you
we live in a me me me me
me world and they forget that really
when you have children you're supposed
to dedicate your life to those children
your feelings don't matter
anymore and women overwhelmingly do not
get a second job even in relationships
that are closer to 5050 the man still
out earn the women typically
um so there were some comments you know
of me just getting destroyed saying
Pearl's just saying things to be honest
and you'll notice that most of the my
critics and detractors are overweight or
older single women Pearl doesn't think
through what she's even saying no guys
I've actually thought it through
completely if you take a vow that says
you are going to do something you should
do it women do not take it seriously in
2023 they like the idea of marriage but
when it comes to actually doing the hard
stuff they don't stick it out so there
was a woman that actually had a divorce
party let's pull it up Gabby what are we
celebrating my
divorce this this is disgusting it is
absolutely disgusting that you would
celebrate the erosion of a family guys
when you grow up in a single mother home
you are more likely to go to prison you
are more likely to be a rapist you are
more likely to be a mass shooter you are
more likely to run away from home you
are more likely to be enrolled in a
mental institution you are more likely
to drop out of high school every
negative thing in society is linked to
single motherhood and yet women parade
and cheer each other on as they do it
the last woman that was criticizing me
said it's not like women just do this
for no reason yet we have women throwing
parties about something that is
genuinely sad something that you are
supposed to take seriously how can we
say women are taking this seriously when
we are having parties celebrating it
that [__] is disgusting that is
disgusting in no world should you be
celebrating a divorce and it's
interesting guys notice that the comment
section when it comes from men is a lot
more honest than from women because
women comments tend to cheer the [__] on
or male comments um tend to really tell
you how it is so this guy but tobani
says it doesn't look like she's happy
about the divorce that's how it looks to
me though um another commenter says I
need a follow up in a year to see if she
sounds like Tyrese's ex yes and a lot of
women leave these situations thinking
the grass is greener on the other side
they think that all the men that give
them
attention actually want to date them
when really they just want you for a
weekend they don't want you long term I
cannot stress this enough the majority
of single mothers do not remarry and if
they remarry they are more likely to
divorce than they are to stay with their
partner 15% roughly of single moms get
remarried 22% get a guy to live with
them meaning 60% the overwhelming
majority do not remarry and why does
every single mother think that she is
special every child you have with a man
decreases your sexual Market market
value by at least a point at least it
doesn't matter how good-look you are you
have two three kids with another guy
you're done don't expect to remarry and
we see this in real time you know
Samantha Lee had no problems getting
divorced from Tyrese everything seemed
good she thought it was the right
decision and last week we covered that
it in fact was not good and now she's
having second thoughts and regretting
her divorce she went out there and dated
again and realized the grass probably is
not going to be greener on the other
side she puts out a video saying that
she regrets it and let's see Tyrese's
response the the truth about the matter
is that if I had different people in my
ear at that time it would not have made
that
decision look man I was not going to
respond to this video of my ex is now
going viral she is loving it
congratulations you went viral again
over something else that you said cuz
you trying to build up your YouTube page
and get your followers up listen man
listen if you had people in your
ear that influenced you into leaving
your husband and your one-year-old child
your innocent one-year-old child we both
were divorce SE kids grew up in toxic
environments torn in between our old
Family new family stepfather
stepmother that's a life that we both
lived and
you packed up a
one-year-old put a CO mask on top of the
rain cameras and I was literally in an
airplane on my way home to fight for my
marriage and my family you're
heartless and it's been 3
years I've moved on I'm with z
ell you moved on I don't even want to
tell [__] the first [__] you started
dating when we broke up cuz you going to
go viral from
that if I were to tell [__] who you
started dating as soon as we broke up
you would go viral from that all you
want is attention you want Facebook
followers you want Instagram followers
you're trying to be a life coach and you
trying to get [__] to drink the
Kool-Aid you [__] with a real one
right
here so a couple things that are
interesting about this clip so he says
if people were to know who you dated
right after me you would go viral so I'm
assuming it's some high-profile guy that
we know that would never commit to her
that she probably thought she could get
commitment from and probably did what
men tend to do with single mother
divorcees which is pass them on to the
next sorry guys guys this is how men
think and you can shoot the messenger
but guys I interview thousands of men
they typically think that divorcees are
for fun only they don't see them as a
long-term option and the data supports
this most single mothers never remarry
ever most can't even get a guy to live
with them again that is the future this
woman is asking for 20K a month to raise
a child what on Earth do you need 20K a
month for I bet he would be fine with
two grand that should cover all expenses
even three I bet you he would even do
five that that can get you a one-bedroom
apartment and pretty much any major city
and I and I even think that's a bit
extreme I I think if you choose to leave
a marriage then you should have a plan
to financially support yourself and the
child the rest of your life no I do not
think that you should be able to depend
on the guy that you are no longer giving
anything in return to I believe that is
legal robbery and I think women that are
legally robbing men should be treated as
such criminals
criminals the third thing he pointed out
is that her mother was in her ear and
ladies this is a tough pill to
swallow a lot of your mothers do not
want to see you
succeed they want to see you just as
miserable as them so you can be her
emotional tampon the rest of her life
because a lot of your mothers have
failed again and again and again in
relationships and they do not want to
see you succeed there are mothers that
are simultaneously telling their
daughters that they love them and
support them while trying to ruin their
marriage this is common I would say this
is more common than it is not and and
the thing is a lot of these mothers are
bitter because they're old and they
don't get the attention they used to
from men and if they knew that one of
the leading reasons that skin begins to
Sag and form wrinkles is not necessarily
because of old age but because our
bodies are missing out on essential
collagen you see we produce 10% less
collagen every decade once we hit 30 and
that's a major reason behind those pesty
wrinkles adding just a little collagen
to your diet can have a noticeable
effect for your skin and youthfulness
preferably the sooner the better that's
why myself along with tens of thousands
of people have turned to this Cutting
Edge new substance to help reduce
visible sides of Aging it uses the top
five most researched types of collagen
which is essential for skin Health to
support skin elasticity and skin
hydration the five collagen types are
difficult to find on their own but
they're all included in every scoop just
mix a serving with your favorite morning
drink to give the skin the building
blocks it needs to reignite a youthful
glow the best part I love is you get 53%
off the rest of the month or until they
sell out whichever comes first plus
you'll also receive additional gifts
valued at over $500 free with every
order for a limited time including VIP
live health and fitness coaching for a
new ebook titled the 14 amazing foods
for skin a 60-day satisfaction guarantee
and free shipping get yours now by going
to health withth pearl.com that's Health
withth pearl.com you will not regret it
so guys a lot of times I hear about the
gender pay up and I was actually having
a conversation with someone this weekend
and it was a feminist of course talking
about oh I'm so oppressed my life is so
hard there's all these reasons women are
not paid as much and I'll say this women
are not paid as much because they're
lazy they don't want to do the hard jobs
and they love to [__] and moan even
though they do less work women want a
work life balance which is totally fine
but what comes with a work life balance
is less pay women love to take vacations
women love to spend money they don't
have and then cry about it later women
are terrible at negotiating and women
tend to have easier jobs so there was a
woman that was on TV that found out live
on air that she was not being paid and
the men were let's pull I'm sorry you're
soed to be paid to go on air in not paid
that is the moment that that woman
realizes that that man has been paid
£200 to go on TV and debate her and she
has not been paid any to debate him and
the entire debate was sparked by the
Lawrence Fox incident which was sparked
by an argument over the gender pay Gap
and he's like so adamant that she'll
have been paid he's just like oh I'm so
sorry that you're so exhausted being
paid to come on TV and debate people and
she's like I'm not being paid are you
being paid I have never seen the
foundations of a debate justify the need
for the debate in that way and please go
and watch that entire video it's just r
ridiculous it's funny because her gut
reaction the feminist gut reaction is
that they must be paid differently
because of gender but maybe it's because
you're just Dumber maybe you don't offer
as good of commentary maybe you're not
as welln there are many reasons why one
person gets paid and another doesn't as
someone that runs a show that actually
thinks these things through I might know
that person a will bring me 10,000
viewers and person B will bring me 2,000
viewers there are some people that get
more value just by coming on the show
than the show gets from them and what
modern women do is they [__] and they
cry and they moan later instead of just
negotiating better and working harder
women wanted to be in a man's world so I
say be in it be in it and fight for your
pay and if you're not going to do that
please do not [__] cry and moan about
being on TV you are a commentator being
a commentator is one of the best jobs on
the planet I love being a commentator it
is much easier than say a plumber a
trucker or a factory worker and so many
times women are entitled to more and
more pay even though they have an
significant advantage in the space it is
much easier to blow up as a commentator
as a woman than as a man the men
typically have to work their whole lives
to get to a point where the women are
typically given that upfront I don't
make the rules I just tell you what they
are look at the daily wire for example
the younger people Brett Cooper Candace
Owens they're both phenomenal they're
both amazing commentators but to act
like they had to do as much work as say
Ben Shapiro Andrew claven and Matt Walsh
is just it's lunacy it's absolute lunacy
and it's okay we all have our strengths
and weaknesses that's okay I'm not
hating on anybody for it but what I am
hating on is women that are given an
advantage in a field and then you're
going to cry about it later her quit
crying and maybe just learn to negotiate
better so the comment section
immediately rushed to simpery why are
Sky News paying the men and not the
women maybe because she's not as good
maybe she doesn't offer as much
value um Taran girl says yeah I just saw
this absolutely enraging um and I just
saw this too and I want to say to shut
the [__] up oh my God Jesus Christ stop
crying I'm so tired of the bitching and
crying um user 381 18887 says this is
why I cannot tolerate anybody who says
the gender pay Gap is a myth well I'm
that Gil the gender pay Gap is
absolutely a myth quit crying and
whining about it one phenomenon that
there is is the fake wives modern women
are fake wives these are women that have
the title of a wife that maybe have been
married but do not have the mindset of a
wife now the number one mindset of a
wife is nothing to do with looks it's
nothing to do with fashion it actually
has everything to do with
selflessness now I talk a lot about
Botox lip
filler hair extensions and Nails there's
nothing wrong with these things by
themselves however typically the
husbands are not the ones pushing this
on their wives the women are pushing
this on themselves in order to get more
attention from other men and not their
husbands now typically in the times of
old maybe the women would have a shorter
skirt and maybe show their ankles or
maybe slightly more revealing clothing
while they were searching and trying to
attract a husband but they knew once
they got married you were expected to
dress and act differently no you are not
expected to act the exact same way
before you get married and after you get
married once you are a married woman you
were expected to not put yourself in
certain situations and not appear as if
you are looking or appear to be
attracting attention for other men your
family's honor is very important but
modern women do not care and I'm seeing
this phenomenon of women trying to get
attention from other men in their
50s the second half of your life isn't
supposed to be about sex let's say on
average we live to be
80 when is it time to put your sexuality
away
when is it time to focus more on your
character than your looks because at a
certain point for everybody looks fade
and I asked this question because I saw
a picture of JLo let's pull it up now
JLo is a beautiful woman um she is
stunning and she is known across the
world for her looks but I asked the
question is this how a wife and a mother
should be dressing her boobs are out
she's in a skin tight dress and you know
at least younger women you can kind of
Chuck it okay they're young they're
naive but this woman has lived half of a
decade and yet she's still dressing like
a a
hooker when is it time to put your
sexuality away so I asked the question
will modern women ever put their
sexuality away this is a mother and a
wife is she still married I I don't even
know women of the past understood that
over a certain age roughly 30 it was
time to dress more modestly why do
modern women feel the need to lead with
their sexuality even in their 50s I I'm
seeing this phenomenon of mothers and
wives it's Halloween time walking around
with their children dressed like skaks
with their kids what example are you
leading for your
children you know JLo has a daughter and
would she want her daughter to be
dressed the way that she dresses so
another woman that I've sort of briefly
followed for a couple years is actually
Haley Bieber and I actually thought it
was like amazing I thought it was
literally amazing that Haley Bieber
could be married to a world-renowned
superstar and she still dresses like a
hooker like on her Instagram there's all
of these pictures of her in underwear
and I always hear the push back I hear
the push back well she was a model and
my question
is will you give up anything to be with
a world-renowned superstar now this is
also on Justin now Justin Bieber doesn't
really appear to me to be the head of
the household and his own family because
he allows his woman to dress like this
and these are the people you know that
were parading around
Christianity so this is Haley
Bieber's um Halloween costume this year
and again I beg the question she's
absolutely beautiful she's stunning she
looks awesome but she's a married woman
is this the image you want to portray of
yourself as a married
woman and again this is why I say there
are many women that look like wives they
may even dress like wives sometimes
obviously not here um but they don't
actually play the part they actually
don't go into that role and you know I
wish them the best but I I just think
that addressing this way is inviting
problems into your relationship you know
and this is a woman married to a
world-renowned
superstar I mean how how can you get
better everybody loved Justin Bieber
back in the day okay so lastly today
guys I wanted to touch on a clip that I
thought was actually hilarious um Joe
Rogan reacting to 24 things that nobody
is better than than Donald Trump let's
pull it up 24 things nobody is better at
than Trump nobody can do it like me
nobody nobody can do it like me honestly
nobody stronger than me nobody has
better toys than I do there's nobody
bigger or better at the military than I
am nobody loves the Bible more than I do
nobody builds walls better than me
nobody's better to people with
disabilities than me nobody's fighting
for the veterans like I'm fighting for
the veterans there's nobody that's done
so much for equality as I have there's
nobody more pro-israel than I am there's
nobody more conservative than me there
is nobody that respects women more than
I do nobody would be tougher
you know Trump is the ultimate picture
of confident it is so hilarious it is so
funny really and truly I think that's
what got him elected is he is really an
Entertainer um and a lot of people have
asked what my opinions are on the
election um I don't follow it as closely
as some people do but right now I am
team Trump I could be persuaded in other
directions but I really when I really
think that Trump was the best president
in my
lifetime um so it'll be interesting to
see if anyone can really go head-to-head
with him I don't see any of the
Republicans doing it but and it'll be
interesting to see if Biden is actually
the one who runs I really think they're
going to find a different candidate but
you know only time will tell okay so
lastly guys every Pearl daily we read a
top comment from the last video so guys
make sure you leave a comment and like
your favorite comment below so crunchy
man 5330 says tradcons be like just be
in the top .01% of men and choose the
right woman it's just that simple okay
guys leave a comment below and I will
read the top one next time like the
video on your way out and I'll talk to
you later